Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Connors. We are going to be talking about a new approach to
helping
block
cancer and stimulate ampoptosis. It's through a specific cell surface protein called the edox
2 protein. There's actually three edox proteins. It's the edox 2 that we're going to be mainly
served with with this talk and you'll see why. The edox 2 protein is the resides on the cell surface,
the cell surface. It is shedded to the bloodstream so it could actually be used as a marker
that, in fact, many of you may have heard about the unblocked test as a marker that is no longer
available due to cost but there's a new test coming out and there'll be a new presentation on that
in a little bit too. So watch for that as a video as well.
Well, it's been determined that this edox 2 protein has the ability to help us manage
cancer. It is a very good diagnostic aid. As I said that there was a test that could read
edox 2 proteins and it became too costly for the lab to continue the test. But in this talk,
we're going to talk about it as a therapeutic target, drug target but actually a nutritional target
and you'll see what I'm talking about. It has two distinct functions. It plays a role in cell
enlargement and cell growth. It also plays a role in a different way to stimulate glycolysis
and these two ways are very important with a cancer patient because if you're stimulating glycolysis
in a cancer patient, you are feeding that cancer and as you know, that's a very big concern
of how we're looking at cancer if we can cut off its supplies. Edox 2, what it is expressed,
it blocks apoptosis and stimulates glycolysis. So it's a very important marker in a sense that
if we have edox 2 expressed, you know that you have cancer. And if we could somehow block
the edox 2 expression, then we could, through the edox 2 pathway, very effectively help a
cancer patient reduce the feeding of the cancer through glycolysis. So edox 1 is a different pathway
that's expressed in all non-cancer cells. It's again a self-surface cell surface edox protein. And
understand these are genes but they're not, this is not a genetic defect so it's important to know that
as well. So we're not looking for a genetic defect. We're looking for the expression of that gene.
Edox 2, cells with this bead expressed always have uncontrolled growth. So it is, it is never
expressed in someone who doesn't have cancer. So that's the benefit of it as a marker but that's also
the benefit of targeting it too. So there is zero-harmoned targeted if you use a substance to target it
that isn't harmful to the rest of yourselves. So what edox 2 does as it's expressed, it enables
basically uncontrolled growth and replication of cells. And that's what cancer is. So that's what
we're trying to prevent. So it is again it's an x-croposome marker though it is a,
it is a gene. Everybody's going to have an edox 2 gene, an edox 1 gene because that's the protein that
it makes is with everyone. Though it won't be expressed if you don't have cancer. So it's very important
to know that we're looking for the expression of the gene, not just the defect itself. So we're not
looking at your genetic test or your 23 and me. Do you have an edox 2 defect? That's not what we're
looking at. We're looking at the expression and those kind of tests become more costly. That's why
that test had gone under. I know a number of my patients had done the uncle block test to do it all
the time. It's just not available anymore. So the benefit of targeting this is that even in very,
very early cancers, long before you can see them with any imaging. So long before you would ever
know that you have cancer, in stage zero cancers, the edox 2 gene is going to be expressed.
So it is one of the first things that it's expressed. It's in tumor agenesis meeting that that's
when the tumor is just beginning. That's when the expression of the edox gene occurs. So there's
there's benefit to even if let's say I don't have cancer, but there's cancer in my family.
You see the things that we're going to talk about in the next few slides can be extremely
beneficial to help prevent that. Meaning I can have, I've said many times that all of us have cancer
growing in a city, depending on if our immune system is taking care of it and winning the battle
or losing the battle that I will eventually get cancer. Well, here's one of the ways that you could
help yourself win the battle or your loved ones win the battle if you have cancer. By using
target and nutrition to help block this edox pathway, you could, if you're going to get cancer,
sometime in your life, you could push it farther out. So it's a very double approach.
Here's the intervention site on the gene. It's kind of complicated as we look at the genes.
And this is where we want to intervene with a drug approach or a nutritional approach.
And as they started studying this, they started to discover that this is actually how some
of the chemotherapy drugs work, which was quite interesting. Like cisplata, a very common chemotherapy
drug, actually one of the mechanisms of action is as it blocks the edox too. Now of course,
these, some of these drugs are extremely harmful to our body. So it's not, we'd have to use them in
a fairly high dose for them to be very effective in blocking the edox to pathway. So they would be
country-indicated. But what they found was two really novel approaches. EGCG from green tea extract
and capsaicin, which is from cayenne, does a fantastic job in blocking this. And there really is no
dose-limited toxicity to either of these nutritional products. I guess you can take too much of it,
but you're not going to have any side effects from this. So taking capsaicin or cayenne pepper
and EGCG, you don't want to just, oh, I'm going to drink a whole bunch of green tea. You'd have to
drink about 100 glasses of green tea to get a bunch of EGCG as you need. But taking EGCG and cayenne
pepper can be a fantastic novel approach to add to literally every cancer picture because
every cancer doesn't make any difference. What type of cancer it is is going to express the
edox to protein. So by by addressing this, this is, you know, I'm trying to get this video to all
our cancer patients because this is new information for me. By adding cayenne pepper and EGCG to your
approach, now I have a number of my patients out EGCG now because EGCG is the really the only way to
deal with interleukin six expression which is inflammatory marker that's found with metastasis
to the bone. So most of my patients that have metastasis to the bone are already heavy on EGCG,
but adding cayenne pepper. So the other patients that I don't have on either one of these, it may be a
good fairly inexpensive way to add just another approach to block the edox protein. We have both
of these available in our store. The standard process product of cayenne is a great product of cayenne,
a good whole food product at our old EGCG. And you could take three to six of these a day.
I'd start off with three a day of them especially with the cayenne as it can be a little sensitive
to your tummy. Take that, take these with food, I would suggest. And you could bump up to six a day
depending on what stage you're at in your cancer. And for a patient who doesn't have cancer for
your loved ones, it could be good to take one to two of these a day to help prevent that because
even again, if you're in the very early stage, undetected zero symptoms, it could be five to ten
years away before you're diagnosed with cancer. If you can start blocking this edox to pathway,
you can prevent cancer. This is what we need to get into more as the prevention of cancer.
And because that's exactly where it targets. So the cayenne and the EGCG, a great intervention to block
the edox too, which is going to be expressed in every form of cancer. So something to put in your
arsenal. All right, thank you.